thank you for joining me this rather
unique experience I'm in the NDC DevOps
Conference of any and I'm staring at an
empty room so we all appreciate that the
last 24 hours has been quite a
challenging experience so I just want to
take a quick minute just to say thank
you so much to the NDC team for doing an
amazing job of switching this conference
to a fully virtual event the AV team
here have been amazing as well and of
course you folks at home who are joining
us remotely you know thank you so much
so with that let's crack on so we'll be
doing QA using slider so you can see the
details there I've also got the videos
on bottom of every slide and I've got
the slider window available to me as
well so please do you go and ask
questions as we go along and I'll try
and answer as much as I can so what
we're going to talk about today so I
want to talk about how we provision
cloud infrastructure
well actually generally infrastructure
in general I want to talk about some of
the limitations we have with that
approach we use and then I want to talk
about a tool that I found extremely
helpful called plumie it's a couple of
caveats I'm going to focus on Asia and
net but the principles I'm talking about
apply to everything so it doesn't matter
what platform you're using and does
matter what language most of what I talk
about is applicable so this talk is
inspired by some of the work I do with
smaller clients who have to deal with
clarity infrastructure and I did want to
also specify that I don't work for
plumie I'm in no ways incentivized by
plumie so this is not a sales pitch so
Who am I well I'm a freelance as a
consultant I specialize in Azure
kubernetes and cloud native technologies
so over the decades over the decade I've
been mostly Donaire developer I also
dabble in some other languages I'm an
MVP and I also co-organized the meetup
in the UK so Milton Keynes taught net
main reason really for this slide is my
contact details oops
apologies let's go back as I said I'll
try and answer questions and slider as
we go along and please do ask questions
on there
if I don't get chance to answer your
question or you just didn't want to ask
ask it on slide I'll do free free to get
in touch with me so when we think about
provisioning infrastructure particularly
in the cloud
the first option that most people start
with is they turn to the portals and the
portals are a great way to get started
provisioning resources for a number of
reasons firstly they're discoverable so
you can figure out what resources and
what options and services that your
cloud provider has by visiting the
portal they also give you wizards that
allow you to start creating these
resources in a very clean stepwise
manner and because they have options
within those wizards you can also ensure
that you pick the right options they can
filter drop-down lists and they can make
sure that you are creating the resource
exactly the way you want without ever
selecting anything invalid
another reason portals are great is
because some people are generally more
comfortable with gooeys now I tend to
like the command line but there's
nothing wrong people who like to prefer
to use the gooeys now there's a few
challenges with the portal the first one
being that it's not easy to repeat what
you did consistently so we as humans are
terrible at repeating things especially
boring mundane tasks sometimes options
you want in the portal can be buried two
or three layers deep and submenus and
you have to click through all of those
to get to those options also if you want
to provision multiple resources things
can be tricky very because there's only
one of you doing the clicking maybe if
you're ambidextrous get yourself a
couple of mice and try and do two
deployments in parallel but that's about
the best you're going to manage and also
you have to figure out the dependency
free so if you let's say you're
deploying the website you probably need
to deploy a storage account first so you
probably need to go and deploy that
first and then deploy your website so
it's with these challenges in mind that
we've come across this term
infrastructures code in the last few
years in particular and essentially what
this says is that rather than manually
or interactively deploying resources we
use some kind of definition for
and of course the first port of call for
these is usually the cloud providers so
we have the agile resource manager we
have AWS CloudFormation and we have
Google deployment manager and of course
I'm sure the cloud provided you use will
have the same and again various private
cloud offerings also have exactly the
same types of options so let's take a
look at a as your resource manager
template now that text is very small but
don't worry we'll dive in a bit closer I
just want you to get a feel for the size
of the template so let's take a look
this a bit closer so here we are we're
setting up some parameters the first
option we're setting up a storage
account type as a parameter we're saying
it's a string and we're giving it a
default value and notice the default
value is a very precise string because
when we are using these templates we
don't have the benefit of the UI giving
us drop-down lists so instead we have to
ensure that people who are using our
template can only select the valued
values so we can do that and we can see
that we can also provide a list of other
options that people can use now as a
template author you need to ensure that
you are using the correct strings there
you need to ensure that you've checked
with the cloud provider and also if they
add any new options you need to ensure
they're available in your now
out-of-date list okay so that's one
parameter let's take a look at another
one so here we're defining a another
screen parameter for the location and
we're setting a default value of
something called a resource group and
we're taking the location from that now
if you haven't noticed already this
template was essentially a JSON file but
when we look at that default value line
what we're seeing there isn't what we
normally seen Jason Falls we're seeing
what looks like a function and that's
the first clue really to where some of
the challenges line using these
templating languages ok so we've got our
parameters we can also create variables
so here what we're doing is we're
concatenating a string called store with
another string that we're deriving from
some kind of function of an ID but again
we're now starting to see these unique
languages
syntax that we're seeing that's built
into what is essentially a screen value
once we have that we can now go ahead
and provision our resources so here
we're creating a storage account and
you'll notice that what we're doing is
we're taking those variables for the
storage account name and we're taking
the location and we're also adding that
the SKU we were picking the value that
somebody would have chosen from that
drop-down list oh it's not a drop-down
list but a list of options and also once
we've created this we can also output
certain values because what we want to
do is potentially pass values from
provisioned resources into other tools
in our tool chain so once we have this
template what we can do is we can now go
and execute we have a number of options
here but in this example we're going to
use the agency Ally are we going to do a
Zed group deployment create and we're
going to pass in the template and the
nice thing with this line is this is
automatable there's nothing special in
this line everything we need to create
the resource is described within the
template file so that's great so we look
at some of these pros we can automate
these and that's precisely what we want
because automation will give us
consistency and of course it stops the
human hand to do the boring things
there can be identity so what this means
is when we deploy the resource once if
we don't change anything and we deploy a
second time nothing changes we don't
create a second instance of everything
they're declarative so you notice in
that markup file we described the state
we wanted we didn't describe how we
achieve this so we didn't say first make
this then make this then make this and
join them together we just said I want
this and that's exactly what you want
because the underlying mechanism of how
those things are created can change and
you don't care and of course as you've
seen now it's very easy to recreate
multiple resources because we have the
template we can execute that with
different parameters every time and we
get more and more resources and largely
the resource dependency is resolved for
us so we've told as a resource manager
we want a storage account and maybe some
other things and it
figure out that we need to create the
dependencies first and then the storage
you can there are some downsides to
cloud templating and we'll spend a bit
longer on these in a few minutes as well
first things they're verbose you saw
that for creating essentially a single
resource we had a whole page of Jason
you also saw that even though it was
Jason there was some very
domain-specific syntax in there so we'd
have to learn this particular syntax now
if we're only using one cloud provider
maybe that's acceptable if you're using
multiple cloud providers that may not be
such a great option of course if it's
not something you do day in day out then
remembering that syntax may also be a
challenge the other the other issue is
that the azure resource manager is
closed source if you wanted to implement
some specific functionality you can't
just contribute a patch or something so
try and tackle some of these issues
people often turn to a tool typically
terraform is one of the most well known
tools so the terraform is corrected by
hoshi cope and it uses its own markup
language called HCL the key difference
with terraform is you can use the same
language the same syntax but target
multiple clouds or multiple platforms
it's open source so if you want to
modify or add additional functionality
you can submit a pull request and
hopefully that gets merged in and you
have the new functionality it's raining
go which is a modern cloud native
language that lots of people are turning
to you so the performance is pretty good
as well of course it depends on the
underlying cloud provider as to whether
you get exactly what you expect so let's
take a look at a resource manager sorry
a terraform template here we're looking
at terraform template which is creating
a resource group and then a storage
account and what we can see is we are
referencing that resource group we Pro
created earlier and we are pulling out
the name and the location from that so
we're saying resource group example the
name and example
location so this allows us to create a
nice template which will have the
dependencies referenced similar to we
had with the arm templates as well so
there are some downsides with terraform
so again it's another special language
and it's a language that only works with
terraform as I said terraform is is
better in the sense that you can a lot
of the syntax you learn a lot of the
functions the special concatenation
functions and everything else will now
be applicable across multiple platforms
and of course as you've seen the
template is is more more concise in my
opinion terraform and many tools like
terraform will have a problem in the
sense that they will always lag behind
the cloud provider so every time a new
functionality or new feature is is added
to the cloud there's inevitably going to
be a degree of lag until a feature is
implemented in in the tool now of course
being open-source if there's something
you want desperately urgently cause open
an issue grab pull request and hopefully
you'll have that functionality as quick
as you can write it tariff room also has
to deal with state and state managing me
management can be an issue in particular
if you're not careful you can have
sensitive information appearing in some
state files which are stored outside of
maybe your normal secrets management
what if you have more complex deployment
scenarios so typically and I'll show an
example of this later we have to do
things like conditional logic so we have
to deploy resources based on a parameter
for example for example we may need to
have loops we may want to have numerous
resources provision in a loop of some
kind and we may need to invoke
third-party code and all of these are
possible with arm templates and
terraform but they introduce a syntax
which is maybe not the most
understandable so let's take a look an
arm template which is doing conditional
logic so here we've got a parameter
called production is type string and
we've said it can be yes
and now we're deploying the website and
we're using a condition element sorry
I'll just click through that condition
element and we're saying if this
condition if the parameter production is
equal to yes then the condition is true
and the resource will get deployed
obviously if that's not yes then you
won't get deployed we look at this and
you'll say well is that yes and no is
that case sensitive I'm not sure if you
work with arm day-in day-out
you'll know this off the back of you
back of your hand and that's fantastic
but if you don't then you have to go
back and look at the documentation
remind yourself and it's easy to make
lots of mistakes like this so let's take
a look at the equivalent example using
Terfel so now Tara forms got a variable
called his prod it's a boolean type and
now what we're doing is in our resource
we say if the if the boolean is true
then it equates to 1 otherwise it's zero
so it's a ternary expression here and
that value is set as a count so what's
happening here is if if it's not prod we
get back a zero so the count is 0 and
terraform won't deploy the resource
because the count is zero so you can see
this is this is a little bit of a hack
really but maybe it's a bit easier to
understand let's have a look at loops so
we're back to arm again we have an array
and it says production or development
and now what we want to do is we want to
loop over this array and we want to
provision resources it's what we're
doing here is we're collecting the name
of the resource by concatenating my app
with the array and then we're indexing
into the array based on the loop we're
currently in and then further down we
have a copy element are essentially
telling the resource manager to copy
this resource any number of times which
is the length of the purpose array
I've been speaking for two days and I
have a bit of a cough so please don't
panic everyone I'm plus for your you
know many miles apart now so we should
be fine let's take a look at the
equivalent so how we do loops in
terraform so now we have a variable it's
a type list and we have dev staging and
prod so now what we're doing is we're
doing a count again
and we're doing the length of the array
and we're just picking the name out from
the index of that Neroni
so as I said these things are achievable
in terraform and arm but if you don't
work with our Foreman arm on a daily
basis they are not the easiest things to
understand so we come back to that
statement about infrastructure as code
and one word stands out to me more than
any other which is the code so I'm a
developer this talk is pretty biased
towards developer perspective in my
opinion and when I look at code I expect
to see modern programming languages I
expect to see constructs I'm familiar
with conditional blocks loops boolean
statements that are recognizable what I
really see is arm and the equivalent in
terraform soaring terraform and in cloud
formation and Google is essentially
markup languages which have had these
programming constructs shoehorn into
them so instead of in fresh Air's code
what about infrastructure software so
it's not - excuse me it's not a term
I've come up with but it's the time
they're starting to gain a bit of
traction
so in particular there's a tool that
I've been starting to use called plumie
so plumies an open source tool and it's
used for provisioning resources and the
key difference with plumie is it uses
modern programming languages so it
sports many platforms and although the
code you will see looks like a
declarative code it's not it is it's
yes exactly the same as the arm
templates it's the desired state so I
said it's open source it's free there is
one component within plumie which isn't
free but as I'll talk about later this
is in no way hampers your usage of glue
me if you want to get started with it so
plume eSports node
- don't Niko and go at the moment
don't Niko and go are currently in
preview I believe that do you - maybe go
GA in within about a month or so now the
model is open and we'll discuss the
model in in a few minutes
so if there's a language you like and
you want to implement it you can go
ahead and implement our language to tie
in typically me terms of platforms
plumie sports a number of platforms you
can see the main cloud providers are
there we can see some infrastructure
providers compared to terraform plumie
doesn't support anywhere near the same
number of platforms but there's a decent
amount here and once again the model is
open much like terraform is if you want
to support a new platform you can
implement and provider yourself and have
support now one half time today to
discuss it
but if you've known if you've followed
my my talks you know that every other
talk I've given our conference has
always mentioned kubernetes in some way
form or fashion so you'll notice that
one of the core providers here is
kubernetes so just to tease you imagine
the concept of using kubernetes and
configuring kubernetes without having to
write a line of yama that sounds quite
interesting and I'll be something I'll
be looking into a lot more going
forwards so how do I get started with
plumie the first thing I need to do is I
need to install the plumie CLI it's
cross-platform CLI and you can just
download that from the plumie website if
you're on Windows I recommend using
chocolaty and you can just do chalk or
install plumie and within a few seconds
you'll be up and running so what I want
to get started what I can do is I can do
plumie new and pass in the name of the
template so in this case it's a c-sharp
template ice asking me for some
parameters and I can just accept the
defaults
after a few seconds it's going to give
me basically a don't need a core project
a c-sharp don't nee core project that's
targeting Asia so we can see there tells
me I'm ready to go so let's take a look
at this project is just created so here
I am in Visual Studio code and you can
see on the left hand side we've got a
program that's es we have a couple of
Yama files and then we have the CS
proach just want to briefly show you the
CS proj so this is the dotnet call 3.1
application and essentially it's a
console application you can see that
there it says output XE and it has a new
gear package reference added plumie
taraji so that's all that is there so
let's dive into the code there's been
enough talking so this is the program CS
and what we're looking at here is the
entry point to the application and what
we can see first of all is we're
creating a resource group so we're doing
new resource group and that resource
group object is coming from the plumie
NuGet package we're passing in a screen
as the name of the resource and we're
creating the variable so the next thing
we're doing is we're creating a storage
account and again we're new in caps
storage you can we're passing on the
screen has the storage account name and
then we're passing these augs so this is
a very common pattern in in plumie in
net you will create the object I mean
pass in an object which contains all of
the options and parameters you want to
set so here what we're doing is we're
setting the resource group name to be
the name from the variable that we
assigned earlier so you notice that we
assigned a variable called resource
group and we're now taking the name
object out of there we're setting
replication type and you account here so
now I've written my code in fact that's
the sample code that gets created as
soon as you create a plumie new template
so what do I do now so if you try and
compile and run that code it's just the
next C you won't do anything because
essentially what's happening there is
that code is being compiled into a
resource graph you sense
that helps plumie figure out what he
needs to create so we come back to the
plumie command-line tool and we run
plumie up and what this will do is
compile the code and then offers
compiled it it will tell us what it
thinks is going to do with this code so
what state is it going to create so
after a few seconds we'll see that it's
telling me I'm going to create a
resource group and a storage account now
I can preview what it's going to do but
in this case I'm just going to go ahead
and say yes so now it's going to compile
the code again I think that's just to
make sure that nobody has changed the
code in the meantime and now you can see
it's going away and it's now creating
these resources so this is talking to my
Azure subscription you can configure
this in a number of ways on your local
machine you can pick up environment
variables if you're using this for any
kind of CI CD system you can use service
principal account so as I'm talking we
are now have the resource group created
and you can see the storage accounts
already created as well and I've asked
bloomie to output the connection screen
from the storage account so that I can
then use it for something else
now don't worry I know the secrets are
visible on the screen but the storage
account doesn't exist anymore so I'm not
concerned and all of that took 33
seconds ok great that was easy because
we're just creating something so let's
take another look and let's make some
changes here so what I'm going to do is
I'm going to add some tags and what you
notice is I'm getting intelligence here
so tells me I can do some tags so I'm
going to add some tags of owner equals
foo okay so now I did the tags I can go
back and run flew me up again and let's
see what's going to happen is it going
to recreate everything
so once again it's gonna claw the code
and it's going to tell me that there's
one resource to update I can dive into
the details of this so if I go down to
the details gives me much more
information and I can see they're just
gonna add some tags to this resource so
it's not going to recreate the resource
it's not going to delete anything it's
just gonna add the the missing elements
so I can go ahead now and do yes confirm
that I want to do the update and bloom
we will go away and now do the update
and I will take you know number of
seconds and there we are so we're done
now so far you haven't seen the
resources is created so this could all
be smoke and mirrors so let's talking to
the portal and take a closer look so
here I am in my resource group that
pluming created and there's the storage
account so just make that bit clearer so
there we are now you'll notice that the
resource group name has this string
appended at the end and so does a
storage account name we said storage was
storage account was called storage so by
default plumie will append random
strings to the end of resource names to
prevent naming collisions now I know
most of you out there or certainly of
coiffure they normally have very strong
naming conventions so you concerned
about well how do I name my resource but
you still have that prefix available so
you can still put the naming convention
in the prefix and just ignore the
additional strings you can override that
behavior and there are very few reasons
why you would so some examples of my PA
domain name and domain name you probably
don't want the random strings at the end
of especially if it's con client visible
but most other things you shouldn't care
about the name of the resource to that
level if you do is probably an
indication that you are heading towards
kind of the pets vs. cattle problem so
once I finished so for example I'm doing
a test or I'm just checking this what I
can do is tear down my resources very
simply so I can run bloom
destroy and I go tell me it's gonna
delete everything I can just go ahead
and say yes and then that will go and
delete the resources now you have to
recognize that it's going to call the
cloud provider and that can take some
time cloud providers are notoriously
challenging in terms of the amount of
time it takes to for things to run so in
this example that video all the other
videos you saw were not in any way
cropped this one was paused and it took
55 seconds but now the resource is gone
so I can see a question from Oleg asking
is there any performance penalty in
terms of deployment time when using
terraform or plumie instead of directly
using arm templates I don't know exactly
to be honest I suspect there are there's
probably marginal differences in there I
haven't had a chance to compare them
myself
but yeah I suspect this marginal if
you've got something that's very time
consuming it would be quite an
interesting one to cry so thank you for
that holic so let's have let's have a
look at the plumie components so I
talked about this language you know you
can write your own language so there's a
language host the language hosts job is
to take the language you've written and
essentially convert it into some kind of
resource tree and that gets passed to
the CLI and actually the plumie engine
and that's really the brains of the
operation
and what that does is that will then
invoke your particular provider and
essentially do crud operations on that
now the state much like terraform
there's a state file created and that
state is stored in some back-end store
so pluming has a number of options here
you can store it in a local disk on the
local machine you can store in a cloud
storage back-end well plumie also have a
console so when i touched on the fact
that a plumie was free and open source
there's one component which isn't which
is this console the console you are
allowed to use as an individual and
we'll take a look at in a second you can
use it in a company setting that has an
individual Omni and you can have as many
projects as you want but if you want to
use it as a team you have to pay for
that additionally unlike many projects
that have a kind of commerce
side to them plumie doesn't in any way
hamper or restrict the core
functionality of the application you can
use the private backing stores and get
the same behavior as you want without
ever using plumie itself one of the
reasons where people don't necessarily
want to use the plumie provided service
is because your secrets may be sent up
there so plumie does encrypt all the
secrets using a per stack encryption key
so there can be stored in source control
if you wanted safely but obviously some
people don't prefer that if you want to
use plumie on on a on premise system you
can also get an on-premise version of
the primi system if you wanted so let's
take a look at that dashboard that I
talked about the plumie console the so
this is the plumie console and it's the
it's just me using it so it's not
causing anything and what I can see is I
can see some stacks I've clicked through
to one of the stacks than one I've
deployed earlier because I have some
other projects on there I didn't want to
show everyone so what I can see here is
that when I ran it I saw the resource
group was created I can see the details
of that and then I can click through and
see the individual steps that were taken
so then I did the tag update so I can
see that and then I can see that it was
deleted so if you're a small team and
you have predominantly one person
responsible for managing infrastructure
you can use this console for free and
it's a great way of keeping track of
what's been going on in your
infrastructure so one of the other
challenges I mentioned was about
invoking third-party api's so using
templates or terraform usually what you
need to do in this situation is drop
down into some kind of script inside the
template the challenge with this is you
can't easily test that script you often
rely on third-party infrastructure to be
available on the machine that you're
running on and often you have to write
this in a different language so you've
now learnt the syntax for the for the
templating language and now you have to
switch to bash or PowerShell and again
you know people who do this day and
there as their job that may be
absolutely foreign
I'm really talking to people whose job
isn't day in day out to be managing the
infrastructure I mean this is very
applicable to everyone
but this is a special case that I've
been finding this really powerful for so
it's giving you more concrete example I
was deploying an azure storage account
and I want you to enable the static
hosting a static hosting and Azure
storage is fantastic way of running
websites static websites and spas
because you run it straight from storage
account you don't have to pay for a web
server and it's fantastically cheap one
of the challenges or the challenge with
with this particular feature is that it
can't be enabled through the resource
manager API that particular option is
not surfaced for some reason so what
this means is arm templates no terraform
no plumie out of the box can actually
enable this feature so if you want to
enable this feature what you have to
normally do is invoke some kind of
script or CLI command so fork out a
process and call the azure CLI and ask
her to enable this feature but I was
thinking well I'm working in a dotnet
core project and I know there's a dotnet
core storage SDK so can I use that so
the example I'm about to show you is
available at that link it's part of the
plumie examples which has got a
repository of quite a large a number of
examples on across the different cloud
providers so let's take a look at what's
going on here so what we're seeing here
is we're creating a resource group like
before recurring a storage account like
we did before
I've specified a couple of other things
that I wanted to have in this particular
storage account but then interestingly
it comes on the next page so we're now
doing this let's dive in a bit closer
first so what we're now doing is doing a
deployment the instant store is dry run
that deployment object is coming from
the plumie environment systolic instance
and it's telling me if I'm running
plumie
am i running plumie preview which is a
way of checking that you your resources
are going to be created as you expect
I'm actually invoking this for real and
what I want to do is I only want to run
this if it's a real deployment and not
and what i'm doing here is i'm taking
the storage account I'm taking the
connection string more specifically and
I'm invoking a function and I'm passing
in the storage connection string so
we'll come back to this snippet in a
second but let's have a look at that
method so this method is now receiving
that connection string and it's using
the azure dominant
call SDKs and it's creating a cloud
storage account using the connection
string what we're doing now is creating
a blob client and we're basically
setting up the static hosting feature
and so we're sending it in able to true
we're giving you some values for the
default documents and we're updating our
storage account once we have that we
come back to our main plumie code and
now we've got an array of files so in
this demo example we've just hard-coded
the list of files the files are in this
repository as well and now we're for
reaching over those files using for each
code that every see shop developer will
we'll know from day one and we're
creating a new blob so this is another
plumie resource object and then we're
setting the storage account name and
we're essentially copying the content
into that blob and what we can then do
is output the resources so when I go and
deploy that eventually will tell me you
created my static site it's created the
blobs and I get back a URL I'm not
showing it here but it's giving me a URL
which lets me then access that static
site so if you want to have a look at
that you can go to the examples repo
I'll put the link up again towards the
end for that so I want to talk about so
far what I've shown you is reasonably
trivial examples so again you could
argue that the plumie code I showed you
is very similar or the start the initial
pluming example of showed you is no more
simpler than the terraform example I
showed you and I would completely agree
with you
so I want to talk about a real scenario
here that I work with so I have a client
who has to deploy a number of web sites
web apps and api's and they put the
application gate
in front of it so the gateway axe has
predominantly a layer 7 load balancer
and also has a Web Application Firewall
and we also have a database so this
client deploys this application in
different environments so prod staging
but they also deploy for different
clients sometimes they have to deploy a
highly available version of this
application and in that situation what
we have to do is we have to additionally
create a traffic manager which is now
the entry point if you like into the
application and that traffic manager
will route or route people to a specific
region so in this example we're setting
up as a a chase a highly available
active active configuration so depending
on where the user is they may get sent
to either the primary or the secondary
region the reason we're doing this is
one the users will get better
performance but also if we have an
outage on one of the regions we will
fail over to the secondary region so
another thing we have to do here is we
have to ensure that the database is geo
replicated and that we've set up a
sequel server fail of a group so the
fail of a group specifically is designed
that if the data centers offline it will
automatically fail the database
connections over to the secondary region
so let's have a think about steps we
need to do to get this to work and then
we think about how we would have done
this using the templating approach so
first of all we need to provision a map
service plan and then provision n number
of web apps so with this client they
sometimes have a variable number of web
apps they have to deploy
we then provision the application
gateway now if you've ever had to
provision the application gateway you
know that doing in the portal is an
absolute pain doing with templates is
also quite challenging because there are
a large number of sub resources you have
to specify and implement one of the
challenging bits with it is you have to
ensure that each each web app is
configured as a route through the
application gateway so if you do add a
new website you need to ensure that you
update the application gateway to also
have a route
to that McKean website you also have to
configure SSL Certificates security
headers and health checks so the
application gateway template becomes
extremely large and excrete extremely
unwieldy you also have to configure the
sequel server database and you have to
capture the details of that because
you'll need that later now if we look at
the multi region deployment we do
everything we do in a single region but
now we need to also capture the Gateway
addresses we need to add sequel geo
replication we need to configure the
fail of a group and then we need to
configure the traffic manager to point
to those application gateways so there's
a lot of things going on here there's a
lot of conditional logic there's a lot
of loops so I'm sure you're dying to see
the code for this sorry to disappoint
you at the moment I can't show you the
code for this the code is currently
specific to my client and I am going to
turn it into an example and submit it to
the examples repo but suffice it to say
that what I'll talk about in the next
couple of slides is the reason why I
looked at using plumie so the clients I
work with often small teams they don't
have dedicated people whose job it is to
manage the infrastructure so these
people are not spending their day day
and they are looking at terraform or arm
templates what I showed you just now to
do in a terraform an arm template is
non-trivial and worse than that once
you've created it if you need to add an
additional root into it you have to
modify multiple places in the template
you often end up having multiple
templates and you have to coordinate
then and sometimes you just copy chunks
of code because there's no other way the
other challenge here is that the team
their primary job is to write code and
there may be using c-sharp and in this
case they are and some front-end code
and now if they want to be responsible
citizens managing the infrastructure
using the templating and everything else
they need to understand the cloud
platform
and they need to understand the
templating language so of course what
most people do is they'll just use the
portal and every time they need to do
again they find that it's just going to
be quicker as painful as it is just to
use the portal again then it needs to
create the scripts because let's be
honest when you create those scripts it
takes a number of iterations to get them
right if anybody can get the arm
template a complex one like that working
first time around
you deserve a gold star because I
certainly can't do it so when I saw that
and I recognized that I was going to
potentially leave this client with some
really complex templates and I was
concerned about that and thankfully
plumie came along just at the right time
so I knew that this team was a dotnet
team of course they didn't have to be we
have tied script you have go you have
Python so I knew that the team as the
general team would be able to recognize
the code now they're not necessarily
going to understand the specific
parameters of storage accounts and web
servers but that's a problem every team
was gonna have to understand anyway if
we can get away from the noise of the
syntax the weird syntax and everything
else and we're looking at loops and if
blocks that they're very comfortable
with they can then hopefully get the
heads around what's going on with the
rest of the syntax and as I said if you
want if you're a big team and you want
to have lots of people managing
resources then you do need to pay for
that but with the smaller teams I work
with we've been able to get away with
without paying anything to bloomie so
let's have a look at some other things
and some other elements and of course
I'll just remind everyone that again
do feel free to ask questions that slide
or the details at the bottom of every
slide so one of the nice things with
preemies and again you can do this with
the other platforms you can create some
really useable components so with
include me there's a stack and the stack
is essentially a group of resources that
can be deployed together and often
stacks are used to deploy the same set
of resources to different environments
whether this is dev staging production
or whether this is a multi tentative
application and you're deploying
individual resources to different
tenants you can create components
get them into a new game file and then
share them with other people in your
organization so put them on your private
registry and share them that way put
them on a public registry if you're
happy to share resources and the nice
thing with this is you can now compose
more complex applications by reusing
these stacks you've created and you can
ensure that everyone gets consistent
configurations now one interesting
challenger can crop up with this is
there's a tendency for some teams or
some some people to create an
abstraction on top of plumie so create
an entirely new abstraction that's
deriving from the plumie code because
they want to restrict access to certain
properties you know for example the
amount to ensure that certain features
and never have any Nabal by somebody so
they create an abstraction on top of the
plumie code to hide that particular
feature and while that's entirely doable
one of the challenges you're face by
doing that is you are creating a whole
heap of work for yourself when the
plumie code and the underlying called
moves forward and it's worth mentioning
at this point that the plumie code and
pluming service and everything else is
beneath writing very quickly it's been
fantastic to see there's been new
versions updated on a regular basis
several times a week and sometimes so
instead of doing that there's a
relatively new feature and Flemmi called
policy as code this allows you to create
policies which can then intercept the
plumie deployments and validate that
what's being created is acceptable to
you or not so an example before where
you want to disable a feature rather
than necessarily doing it that way you
can set a default value for example that
hits it to be off you can use a policy
which prevents somebody from ever
switching it on the advantage of doing
it this way is that you're not creating
a whole nother layer of abstraction
around the plumie code I remember that
is also an abstraction on top of other
providers and other things ultimately
said an abstraction on top of the cloud
provider and also what often happens
when you create these abstractions is
you will find a legitimate reason to use
feature X that you disabled you have to
cry yet another abstraction which then
does enable that feature maybe disable
something else
and you'll get yourself in a mess so the
polytheist code is really powerful
concept and I'm really excited to see
the support for that I don't believe
you're currently has they don't name
call support or certainly there's not
many examples in the documentation but
I'd be looking at that so this all
sounds really great but you've got a
whole heap of existing resources and
you're thinking about what do I do
luckily you've actually got quite a
flexible approach to this so you have
three and broadly three options what you
can do is you can leave your existing
resources exactly as they are and let
them Koya guests alongside plumie and
plumie won't interfere with them we can
also do is adopt existing resources now
this doesn't generate the dotnet code
for you unfortunately but what it does
let you do is essentially reference that
resource and then use it in some of the
other code examples and let plumie take
over the kind of lifetime of that of
that resource then the final option is
you either rewrite or you generate your
plumie code if you are using something
like terraform so there's a tool that
generates a pluming code from terraform
and you can have a look at that now I
don't think I've done this topic justice
there was a a guide published literally
a couple of days ago which is fantastic
and I recommend having a look at that if
you're looking at adopting this so
hopefully I've shown you that I think
there's quite a few pros here
so using plumie lets you use the
languages you're familiar with and
that's really powerful for teams and
especially for teams who don't spend the
day dealing with arm and terraform
because you have the power of modern
languages as long as they have SDKs that
run in the same language you can build
them into the same pipeline into the
same lifecycle management and it's all
integrated I think it's quite easy to
get started with plumie as well because
again I'm not having to learn the syntax
all I'm focusing on is what's the
parameters I need for a storage account
what's the parameters I need for a
database and as I said it's free and
open source and the only option are the
only component you don't have access to
is this bloom
but it doesn't in any way hamper you
from using clue me there isn't a bunch
of features which are disabled because
you don't you haven't paid for them so
everything is fantastic
obviously unicorns and rainbows you know
there are some drawbacks so there's
fewer platforms compared to terraform
now of course if your platform supported
then hey that's not a problem
much like terraform there is a lag
between the release of a feature and
support for really me and the azure
provider now in fact I think some of the
other providers as well they are
actually using the terraform provider
behind the scenes and I do want to take
a moment to to really call this out
because I don't want this talk to be
terraform is terrible and gloomy is
fantastic because plumie the donate call
support include me wouldn't exist if it
wasn't for all the amazing work that
terraform team do and because it's open
source plumie have been able to use it
so a big shout out there to the
terraform team and again you still need
to learn and discover the cloud
providers kind of resource IP on you
need to figure out what parameters they
want for a storage account and again
that's not a plumie specific problem but
I just thought I'd mention it I've done
it earlier but of course when you're
writing c-sharp code you have syntax
checking and you have a compiler so if
you try and reference a resource that
doesn't exist or more likely if you make
a typo and you don't create type the
correct name you'll get a compile error
which is fantastic so you'll catch a lot
more errors much much sooner so your
loop your controller your feedback loop
rather is much much smaller but there
are still some errors that won't crop up
until you try and actually deploy the
code which blew me up now this isn't
necessarily a problem with plumie it's
not their fault it's usually because the
cloud providers API doesn't surface this
option or doesn't surface this
validation logic in any way and you only
discover the problem when she try and
actually deploy the resource it's also
possible to get plumie into a bit of a
bad state the way I've done it quite
often is by canceling a deployment
Midway and what usually happens here is
the the call to the cloud provider has
already been made
the cloud provider is busy provisioning
the resource and obviously everything's
happening any synchronously and now I
cancel the plumie up command plumies now
got in a bit of a mixed state it doesn't
quite understand what state the cloud
providers in what state it's in so
they're very clearly warning not to do
this but when you're doing a dev or a
very kind of proof-of-concept deployment
it's just a quicker way sometimes to
stop fix your mistake and start again
when it does go wrong there are ways of
recovering that so this point when
you're looking at me using c-sharp code
and don't man you've probably familiar
with some of the SDKs are available so
there's an azure net SDK so you might be
thinking about why don't I use the Agora
SDK why do I need to use this
third-party tool fundamentally what most
of these SDKs do is they are they're
abstracting a rest call behind the
scenes most of the time what you're
actually doing is issuing imperative
rest commands to provision resources so
you're not giving them a desired state
you are issuing step-by-step what you
want to create they're not necessarily
idempotent so what might be happening is
you may see the command twice you'll get
two sets of resources and also because
the imperative and because they are not
tracking the current state they're not a
desired state you don't know what your
current state is when you are making a
change you can only really reason about
the new to new state you're making
alongside this is another class of tools
which generally take a general-purpose
language and turn it into the templating
language of the cloud provider AWS has
this cdk and again it looks fantastic
because you're using c-sharp code and
everything's wonderful ultimately it
generates cloud formation templates
behind the scenes if you're on the AWS
fantastic that might be the perfect
option for you but of course it only
works on AWS another option is farmer
which uses f-sharp code and this
generates arm templates and again both
of these options if you have existing
deployment pipelines and mechanisms that
deploy templates then these can slot
into that very nicely and they're a
perfectly valid option incidentally the
dotnet support does include f-sharp if
you are on a flop folk and I know
there's quite a few out there you can
use F sharp to use with blue me as well
so the way I like to think of this and
and I promise you this is slightly
tongue-in-cheek but when I look at the
evolution of this cloud provisioning we
start with the portals kind of move up
to this templating are we coming on to
terraform and then eventually we're now
evolved to using plumie if you want to
learn more the examples I showed the
example I showed you is on the github
there I will add the multi region
example um they as soon as I've done it
and and checked over my client the slack
channel for plumie is fantastic I have
to say massive shout out to the folks on
the slack Channel they've answered
questions within minutes of me posting
them they fixed bugs the next day and
they've helped me figure out some of the
more quirky syntax within pulling me so
thank you so much for them I really made
it my life a lot easier and I have
blogged at least one example that stores
you can example I've blogged in a little
bit more detail on my blog and I'll
probably be adding more examples as we
go along so with that we'll say thank
you very much my contact details are
here and I'll leave that slide up and
again if you've got questions please do
use the slider link so you can join it
slider comm and it's y8 6:04 the code I
can stay here for a couple of minutes
and see if any questions pop up if not
we can we can wrap up and if you've got
any questions I don't get to you then
feel free to ping me an email or tweet
or DM